my dream phone is just combining other
good pieces of other phones so like I
would take the screen from the s22 ultra
it's incredible but then I would take
like the chip from the iPhone and I
would take the charging from xiaomi's
phone and I would take the cameras the
chips sorry the CPU uh xiaomi xiaomi
xiaomi is a Chinese company
xiaomi makes some crazy fast charging
phones okay the iPhone is one of the
slowest charging phones in the world you
probably don't care maybe because it's
fine maybe you're using the USB a that's
a slower I don't know if you know that
it's a little faster all of the iPhones
are slow charging 15 watts just for some
context you guys know xiaomi you know
that [ __ ]
I know why why why why why why why
it's similar they're competitors I know
plus one again one plus yeah yeah
okay but like your phone might charge in
an hour zero to 100 an hour that's
pretty good right uh xiaomi phone will
will drop like a hundred watt charging
and charge up in like 17 minutes zero to
a hundred in 17 minutes wow which seems
insane like I would take that from that
phone right yeah uh I would take these
cameras the battery over the long term
theoretically no but because it's all
heat management like Heat's bad for
batteries and pumping tons of power into
a battery is going to generate heat but
they will go overboard on Cooling and
make sure it's like oh yeah this thing
never gets hot okay so theoretically no
okay that's kind of all I can tell
um but I've you know use the phones and
you you charge it up and it's crazy fast
I just think it's so convenient to like
oh I've got 20 I'm about to go out let
me just plug it in for three minutes
that's all I needed okay so you said and
then cameras from cameras I would
combine the pixel and the iPhone's
cameras right now I would take the still
photos from the pixel and the videos
from the iPhone and and then operating
system I would take Android from the
pixel over Apple yeah yeah and this is
like a personal preference but I'm a
customization guy I like messing with
the way my phone looks I've heard if you
were like if you look at the phone like
a computer and you want to customize
then Android and if you're just we feel
like us yeah you just want to text and
you know every iPhone home screen looks
the same it's 40 whatever icons folders
that's it seamlessness though like
between all the products of an iPhone
that is nice I would you know there are
kind of pseudo other ecosystems that
work similarly and I think like Apple's
ecosystem is pretty good but as far as
like I use a Smart speed speaker Google
makes one of those I use like a smart
doorbell a smart camera there's Google
there's another ecosystem there are
other ecosystems you can make it work
yeah yeah so I'm I wouldn't be missing
like the home pod or anything like that
oh dude they gotta let you make a phone
yeah that actually be a really cool
experiment I'm trying to say what
outside company would do that where they
would make this mutant phone yeah and
there's also a difference though between
the mutant phone that I would want for
myself and the mutant phone that I think
people would work yeah okay so what's
the people buy because the one that
people would buy would be closer to like
is Asus makes a phone called the Zenfone
9 okay I would take that it's a smaller
phone it's got a great fast screen but I
would take a fast screen from like a
smaller iPhone like give me the iPhone
Pro 120 hertz OLED in that Asus Zenfone
so I'd start with a smaller body I'd go
with a smaller camera and I'd make a
little bit of a cheaper phone because
the phone I want would be like three
thousand dollars it would be all the
nicest things from every phone of course
of course the phone that I would make
would probably be you'd have to be
competitive with price that's part of
the things people want and a good phone
so it would be nine hundred dollars you
can just do the Apple thing where you
sell that one and then walk us up with
three that's true that's true has anyone
Frankenstein this and actually put that
battery into an iPhone or what's the no
it's tough like these phones are so like
tightly packed like you can kind of
maybe if you want do well I mean yeah
they're they're all kind of just put
they're just built like if you like the
Samsung screen you can't get that screen
on another phone if you like this Google
camera that's the only one I'm so sorry
I'm like I'm so curious you're at this
point where you have so much consumer
trust right and usually when you have
consumer trust in the industry uh well
not usually but a lot of people go turn
that into consumer goods right you're in
this perfect position where everybody
goes hey he tells us the truth about the
product yeah
now if you put out a consumer good that
sucks they'll lose all faith in you gone
but if you put out a consumer good that
is good
that trust continues and you're
monetizing it on the other side have you
thought about putting out a headphone or
any type of piece of tech it is the
Natural Evolution of what I for a long
time been thinking about this I don't
know what that product would be yet
because of the behind the scenes that
I've observed in so many of these
categories where I want that level of
input but I don't know if it's possible
to do exactly what I want but yes uh I
think the the obvious way of
capitalizing on this trust is to make a
product somewhere in the sphere of
things that I review yes and and I
wouldn't even look at it as like only
capitalizing it's like providing the
product that you know the people want
feeling something that doesn't exist yet
yeah exactly yeah the phone is hard but
you know there's lots of accessories
there's lots of and even some of my
fellow creators have made really
interesting things like cases or Stan
laptop stands things like that like
there's cool stuff out there which is
nice and they're actually unique and
really useful because they're a Creator
and they think like what we want yeah
like I want that too yeah so yeah
there's stuff there's definitely for
sure it's gonna happen I just don't know
what it is oh I mean the line online
store because then you don't need to
worry about like that product you can't
push your product if you know that
there's actually better products have
been developed because all the money
that's behind them but an online store
of your best reviewed items just an
honest review too like what you wish you
did different about it that's what I
pictured I was like I need to review my
own phone yeah and then say the things
that need to be said about the phone
because other people are going to review
it too and they're going to find the
same thing yeah this hurts to say
because I fought really hard for this
but yeah exactly yeah that's interesting
yeah they say um the tech that we're
using now the government has Tech that's
like light years away have you ever seen
some [ __ ] that like has blown your mind
that a little bit I think I asked Neil
deGrasse Tyson kind of a similar
question along the same lines and he's
like yeah there's endless examples in
the space programs and things like that
as far as what I've seen
basically a lot of these companies as
part of their like
showboating a little bit and like making
you feel good they'll show you the
behind the scenes of things and like
unreleased products and like what went
into making some stuff I've seen some
stuff that is like
like really far out that they started
with and then they sort of like shave
down into a normal looking product and
some of that is really curious like in
the car world there's crazy Concepts in
the uh Laptop World come on give us a
little something the car under the tarp
that I can't talk about you know there's
a lot of those that are like yeah we
started with this and sometimes they
show that at like CES they'll show you
like a crazy sub car that's never going
to exist yeah and they'll go damn that'd
be kind of cool yeah yeah and then that
car never ships but then a year later
one with the same name will ship that
looks kind of a little bit like it but
not really I remember Nokia was did a
YouTube video about how they were going
to make a phone you could like change
the shape of it to charge it sucks
around your wrap around your wrist and
all that and it was like I was watching
it the first time I was so cool then I
watched it again I was like this phone's
never coming never happened yeah Elon
Musk is the one that says he wants his
the the prototypes to look like the real
thing so like the Cyber truck is coming
out when it looks exactly like I think
that's smart because that's the real
thing lots of companies they'll make a
sweet looking concept car and it never
comes out and then the car like the
Porsche did this with the like Mission e
and I was like that's a sick looking
like crazy electric car for their first
EV and then the taikan came out and it
was like a normal looking car but it had
the wheels from the concept car yeah
what's up guys that clip was brought to
you by rocket money okay this is the
personal finance app that allows you to
manage subscriptions lower bills build a
custom budget and grow your savings all
in one place that's right they're
canceling unwanted subscriptions for you
safely and secure you don't even got to
call up a company they got your back
they're low in your bills they're
literally negotiating your bills for you
all you got to do is send them a picture
of the bill Tap a button and they got
your back and monitoring your credit
card score and much more so if you're
ready to save some money go to
rocketmoney.com flagrant or click the
link in the description below to get
started for free or unlock even more
features with premium that's
rocketmoney.com flagrant to get started
for free click the link in below